BOTTOM THIS MARTIN LUTHER KING
DAY.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHOLE STAIRCASE, DR. KING SAID
MORE THAN 50 YEARS AGO.
FAITH LAST WEEK IN THAT
AND ALTHOUGH HE DIDN'T SEE THE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, ALL
OF THEM THAT WERE PRESENT, WHAT
HE NEEDED TO GET DS.
HE NEEDED AN END TO CHAIN
MIGRATION, AND THE WALL IN
EXCHANGE FOR A PATH TO
LEGALIZATION FOR THOSE 800,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
TWO DAYS LATER THE DEMOCRATS,
ACTING IN BAD FAITH ALONG WITH
LINDSEY GRAHAM, PRESENTED HIM A
DEAL THAT THEY KNEW HE COULDN'T
ACCEPT.
IT INCREASED CHAIN MIGRATION AND
DID NOT SUFFICIENTLY FUND THE
WALL.
A TOTAL NONSTARTER.
SO AFTER THE PRESIDENT NIXED IT,
SENATOR DURBIN RUSHED OUT TO
MISCHARACTERIZE OFF-COLOR
REMARKS ABOUT THE CORRUPTION IN
THE THIRD WORLD THAT DRIVES
CITIZENS OF THOSE COUNTRIES AWAY
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT SET OFF A FIRESTORM.
EVERYONE FROM AL SHARPTON TO
TRUMP TOXIC ON THE ISSUE OF RAC
THIS FURTHER POISON THE WELL.
BLACK CAUCUS PREDICTABLY ARE
PILING ON.
>> I CALLED HIM A RACIST,
DEPLORABLE, DESPICABLE.
ADDED TO WHAT OTHERS ARE CALLING
HIM, A MORON, IGNORANT, ON AND
IS A RACIST?
>> I THINK HE IS A RACIST.
>> Laura: IF I WERE A
CONSPIRACY THEORIST AND WATCHING
HOW THIS WHOLE THING HAS PLAYED
OUT, I WOULD ALMOST WANT TO SAY
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON HERE.
THE DEMOCRATS CANNOT AFFORD FOR
TRUMP TO BE SUCCESSFUL,
PARTICULARLY AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WAS 7.9% IN
POINT TO 6.8%, THAT'S A RECORD.
WEEKLY EARNINGS FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS UP NEARLY 2%.
HOME OWNERSHIP AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAS KICKED UP
POLICIES FOR BLACK AMERICA AND
THE LEFT'S TRAGIC RECORD, THEY
HAVE DECIDED TO DEMONIZE THE
PRESIDENT AS A RACIST.
IT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
DISTURBING DURBIN WENT SO FAR AS
TO CLAIM AS THE PRESIDENT WAS
>> WHEN IT CAME TO THE ISSUE OF
CHAIN MIGRATION, I SAID TO THE
PRESIDENT, DO YOU REALIZE HOW
PAINFUL THAT TERM IS TO SO MANY
PEOPLE?
AFRICAN-AMERICANS BELIEVED THAT
THEY MIGRATED TO AMERICA IN
CHAINS AND WHEN YOU SPEAK ABOUT
>> Laura: WHILE, THEN WE FOUND
THIS.
>> THE DREAM ACT WOULD NOT ALLOW
WHAT IS KNOWN AS CHAIN
MIGRATION.
IN FACT, DREAM ACT STUDENTS
WOULD HAVE VERY LIMITED ABILITY
TO SPONSOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
>> Laura: ONE TRUMP USES IT IS
RACIST, WHEN HE WAS IS THAT JUST
DESCRIPTIVE.
INCIDENTALLY, LINDSEY GRAHAM,
WAS SUPPOSEDLY UPGRADED THE
PRESIDENT FOR CALLING CERTAIN
COMPANIES S-HOLES, HAD NO QUALMS
USING HIS OWN STRONG ANGUISH.
>> THE PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
THIS, THEY LIVE IN HELLHOLES.
OUR PROBLEM IS WE CAN HAVE
EVERYBODY WHO LIVES THEY'RE
COMING TO AMERICA.
OUR GRANDMA AND DURBIN RACIST?
IF WE APPLY THE
SAME LOGIC WE'LL WANT TO APPLY
TO TRUMP, THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
IF THE LEFT IS NO CIRCLING THE
WAGONS ON THIS.
NOW WE LEARN THAT JOHN LEWIS,
MAXINE WATERS, FREDERICA WILSON,
REMEMBER WITH THE COWBOY HAT,
AND A FEW OTHERS ARE BOYCOTTING
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
IT GOT TO BE KIDDING ME!
THEY SHOULD ALL BE ATTENDING TO
THANK THE PRESIDENT FOR ALL HE'S
DOING TO BETTER THE LIVES OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
ON MY RADIO SHOW TODAY AUTHOR
AND HOOVER INSTITUTION FELLOW
SHALL BE STEEL HAD THESE CHOICE
WORDS FOR CONGRESSMAN LEWIS.
>> JOHN LEWIS IS -- LACKS THE
IMAGINATION AND HAS BEEN SO WELL
REWARDED FOR HIS HISTORY OF
PROTEST THAT HE JUST KEEPS
BEATING THE DRUM, HE KEEPS
TRYING TO PROTEST THINKING THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO GET US
AHEAD.
IT'S NOT.
PROTEST IS OVER FOR BLACK
AMERICANS.
WE HAVE TO ALLOW THE INDIVIDUAL
DEVELOPING THEIR SKILLS, THEIR
TALENTS, COMPETING IN THE WORLD.
>> Laura: IF THE CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS AND CELEBS IN THE
FIELD OF ENTERTAINMENT AND
SPORTS, IF THEY REALLY WANTED TO
HELP STRUGGLING MINORITIES, THEY
EXPAND ECONOMIC AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE SCHOOL CHOICE
FOR ALL PEOPLE.
BUT THANKFULLY I WAS ACTUALLY
HEARTENED BY THIS.
CONGRESSWOMAN SHEILA JACKSON LEE
HAS NOT ANNOUNCED PLANS THAT SHE
WILL JOIN THE NO-SHOWS AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
LET'S BE REAL, IT WOULD TAKE A
NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST FOR HER TO
GIVE UP THAT CAMERA READY
REAL ESTATE SHE ALWAYS OCCUPIES
A MALE.
SHE ALREADY
THERE CAMPED OUT?
TEND TO HAVE A BETTER HANDLE ON
THE TRUTH THAN THE SWAMP
DWELLERS HERE IN WASHINGTON.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO A FEW OF
MY COLORS FOR MY SHOW TODAY.
>> WE ARE DOING MUCH BETTER
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP THEN WE
DID WHEN WE COUNTED ON OUR OWN
PERSON, SO TO SPEAK,
HE WOULD INDEED DO WHAT
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT.
INSTEAD, HE DIVIDED AMERICA.
TRUMP IS NOT A RACIST GUY.
TRUMP IS TRYING TO GET EQUALITY
FOR AMERICANS.
AND SOMEHOW EVERYBODY'S THINKING
ALWAYS SO RACIST.
IT'S A RACIST COMMENT, AND HE'S
NOT.
HE JUST WANTS WHAT'S BEST FOR
AMERICANS, BLACK, WHITE OR OTHER
AMERICANS, BLACK, WHITE OR OTHE
OTHER.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHY I LOVE
RADIO.
YOU HEAR FROM REAL PEOPLE EVERY
DAY.
IT'S MY OWN FOCUS GROUP,
ONGOING.
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS WHETHER
DEMOCRATS HAVE THEMSELVES SO
WORKED UP INTO THIS RACIAL
FRENZY.
THEY ARE PETRIFIED OF A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
DELIVERS TANGIBLE ECONOMIC
RESULTS FOR BLACK AND HISPANIC
AMERICANS.
DEMOCRATS ARE RACIAL MONOPOLISTS
AND THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED DON'T
LIKE ABOUT TO ALLOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO BREAK THEIR
STRANGLEHOLD ON THE BLACK AND
HISPANIC VOTERS WITHOUT A REALLY
NASTY FIGHT, WHICH IS WHAT YOU
ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
CHECK THIS OUT.
THE ATLANTIC IS REPORTING THAT
THE PRESIDENT'S SUPPORT AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IS UP.
IF THAT'S THE "ATLANTIC"
MAGAZINE.
NOT A CONSERVATIVE THINK TANK.
IN FACT, THAT SUPPORT AMONG
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED BACK IN 2016
ONLY 13% OF BLACK MEN SUPPORTED
TRUMP.
NOW ACCORDING TO A NEW SURVEY OF
MORE THAN 600,000 PEOPLE, TRUMP
SUPPORT AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MEN IS UP TO 23%.
HE HAS ALSO GONE UP SOMEWHAT
WITH BLACK WOMEN FROM 4%, A
PATHETIC NUMBER IN 2016, TO A
LITTLE BIT BETTER 11% IN THIS
LATEST POLL.
I'M TELLING YOU THIS.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, THE OLD DEMOCRATIC
CHARGES AND HYSTERIA WILL LOOK
MORE AND MORE UNHINGED.
IT IS THIS REALLY WHAT
DR. KING'S VISION FOR HIS FELLOW
AMERICANS AND FELLOW BLACK
AMERICANS.
AND TODAY, WHO WAS CLOSER TO
HELPING MORE OF OUR CITIZENS
REALIZE THAT VISION?
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO IN A YEAR
HAS ALREADY SHOWN INCREDIBLE
RESULTS?
OR DEMOCRATS, WHO, WHEN THEY